Daniel lovely to see you how hard is it
being bond the endless pressure on the
weight of expectation the endless
working out the endless kind of
speculation about your future it's a
tough gig no it's just it's great fun
and it's so it's just a privilege to do
do you've enjoyed Alzheimer's bonds all
my time as well yeah I have I mean it's
just it's a it's a it's a very it's a
rare thing it's like you know themselves
you know you could just sort of like
enjoy as much as you can it's hard work
and you know any any any good thing is
hot it's hard work but I kind of relish
that and you know I just love working
with the team that we have it's like a
proper family and we've been working
together for a long time now so we know
each other very well so you know we're
family and I mean the most successful
British film of all time is some really
really hard thing to top isn't it but
then that's a good thing it just shows
how successful bond continues to be over
and over again yeah you hope so I just
think that on the back of successes it's
a nice place to be as opposed to be on
the back of failure so you know I we've
we've we've put everything we could into
this to try and it's not about topping
Skyfall it's just about continuing yet
you know to make you know say we did a
great job of Skyfall we've done a great
job inspector where the plot lines is
surveillance do you think in this
country that we're over monitors I think
that's a very tricky question to ask
because I think it's worldwide isn't it
I mean yes is the simple answer I think
there's too much surveillance and
there's too much information gathering
but there's an argument for and against
and I don't think I raise our game to it
right now and to continue the endless
speculation about your future and what's
your answer on whether or not you're
gonna continue I don't know but simply
that that's the simplest answer I can
give
I just don't know at this moment I just
want to enjoy this well I mean what will
decide it with you for you will it be
time or distance I honestly am not
giving it any thought I mean it's just
it's just not on my agenda at the moment
I'm just trying to sort of in
the this process of upselling this movie
and and and you know having some you
know celebrating with the people who
were involved because it's been a long
hard slog and we just I mean we're done
now and we want a you know you know
raise a glass and enjoy ourselves
do you find it kind of baffling stroke
annoying that everyone so interested in
it no because it's that's the interest
is you know it's it means that we're
we're kind of doing the right thing I
mean people with hopefully people the
only thing that matters now at the
audience that's the only thing that
matters beyond all water press are
saying and whatever said in the press or
how it's twisted around or whatever it
doesn't matter I don't look at it nobody
is I know really looks at it or
interested in the audience getting to
see and for them to enjoy it as much as
possible and one of the amazing things
about bond is the fact that it's
continued for so many years and the fact
that it's constantly reinventing itself
just going forward to the future when
you may not be doing bond can you ever
see a future with female bond or a black
bond any anything anything's possible
I mean that's the wonderful thing about
you know this business it's like it's a
you know you know you can you can do
anything and as long as it's credible
and it works and it's you know it's it's
good then it doesn't matter do you think
maybe it does matter they cuz bonds such
an institution isn't it's such a brand
maybe it should be doing something brave
maybe it should be doing something
different to make a statement maybe yes
maybe I'm finally and sorry to
completely change the tone but and you
recently signed a petition calling for
more action on the refugee crisis do you
feel like enough is being done that we
as a nation are doing enough what do you
think we should be the thing we can
always do more always do more it's a
huge humanitarian crisis and we can I
have to step up to the plate do you
think Britain should be taking more
refugees
that is a difficult question to answer
that probably yes